[Music]
Mama June celebrating one year of
marriage and calling out the haters who
didn't think it would last
this is
not a person you can be treated like a
queen on Thursday the reality star
posted a series of snaps to commemorate
her first wedding anniversary with her
best friend Justin Stroud Justin has
taught me not to become a runner and
feel the emotions and it feels good to
kind of be grounded for once in my life
Mama June kicks off the caption pointing
out that people didn't want them to be
together and thought they wouldn't make
it we have been through a lot to say the
least as friends and as a couple that
most would not be able to handle but
Mama June says they've worked through
every situation together something she
says she's never experienced before most
relationships don't go through the
obstacles that we have had to go through
the last year
um and they don't even go through it in
their lifetime of their relationships I
think honestly that's made us stronger I
can't wait to see what the future holds
because I know all the good the bad and
whatever life throws at either of us we
will get through it together
and she wraps it all up praising her man
for allowing her to feel true love
Mama June and Justin said I do in an
Oceanfront ceremony in Florida in
February nearly one year after their
Courthouse marriage in Georgia the
reality star's daughters Honey Boo Boo
pumpkin Chubbs and chickadee were all in
attendance June says it was the first
time they were all together since 2014.
I mean for somebody who just because she
knows what love is and that this is true
but everybody like and she tells me that
with everybody and it's it's different
with this one now it's different with
Justin and I'm not saying Justin's a bad
guy by any means but I also don't know
him that well June's strained
relationship with Honey Boo Boo and
pumpkin played out publicly over the
last few years as she faced addiction
and legal struggles he's also in
recovery so how does that work with the
both of you are you uplifting each other
on this journey yes yes oh yes oh yes
you know you gotta find somebody who
understands you know people a lot of
people say well to act two recovering
addicts cannot who in recovery cannot be
together that's a lot we're going to
prove that that little five percent in
the relationships don't work as for Mama
June's daughters they told E.T last year
their mom's elopement came as a big
surprise I was more in shock because my
mama always said that she would never
get married she was scared of marriage
like to say the least and now she went
off and just got married with this dude
she hadn't even known a whole year yet
but for June she says meeting Justin
changed her life for the better I was
going through some hell learning who I
was but this is you know
this person was right here the whole
time I started really liking him and
opened up the chapter of our story
September of last year and
you know eight almost eight months ago
you know it's been a whirlwind
[Music]
thank you